[Musica]
ma io in realtà serie qui per parlarvi
di prevenzione qualcosa che conosciamo
tutti benissimo immaginò prevenire
prevenire è meglio che curare lo
sappiamo tutti ed è verissimo non solo
per quanto riguarda l'igiene orale per
cui derivava ma più in generale per
quanto riguarda la salute quasi ormai
quasi due anni che non parliamo d'altro
a prevenire cosa significa se via
arrivare prima no prima che si
verifichino problemi prima che sia
troppo tardi prima che accada il peggio
quindi guardiamo in avanti e agiamo nel
presente per evitare che poi si possono
avere problemi quindi un comportamento a
rischio il contagio da parte di un germe
patogeno anche un alimentazione
un'igiene poco accurata sono tutti
ambiti possibili di prevenzione
guardiamo in avanti e interveniamo nel
presente per evitare i problemi questo è
prevenire ed è meglio che curare cioè
intervenire solo quando invece i
problemi si sono già presentati
ma è sempre così
voglio dire è così anche quando non si
parla di salute
prendiamo il mio lavoro io mi occupo di
formazione e questo significa che io
accompagno le persone imparare
ora noi siamo abituati a pensare che
imparare sia un modo per prepararci a
prepararci alle interrogazioni tre
verifiche agli esami degli studenti non
diciamo che sono preparati dalla scuola
fino all'università e anche dopo ci
scriviamo ai master oppure frequentiamo
corsi di formazione per prepararci a
fare bene a fare meglio
un lavoro e allora ci potrebbe sembrare
che imparare e prevenire abbiano
effettivamente dei punti di contatto
in tutti e due casi ci prepariamo ma in
un caso lo facciamo con l'apprendimento
e nell'altro con i vaccini all
allenamento l'alimentazione
tutti convinti
vediamo un po a me è sempre sembrato
affascinante che il processo di
apprendimento avesse qualcosa in comune
con quello di immunizzazione che
pensateci bene quando ci vacciniamo ci
viene inoculato ormai lo sappiamo tutti
una piccola quantità di germe patogeno
attenuato e questo serve ad allenare il
nostro organismo e reagire no quindi
scatenare la risposta immunitaria come
se dovessimo ammalarci e un pochettino
ecco chi si occupa di disciplina e
cognitive ha studiato il processo
dell'apprendimento mettendo a punto un
modello che si chiama you shape della
ring l'apprendimento a forma di u
ha cioè osservato il fatto che quando
impariamo cominciamo da una buona
competenza che poi all'improvviso sembra
sparire per qualche momento e poi
ricompare è strano questo è vero
soprattutto per certe forme di
apprendimento per esempio quello
linguistico e i ricercatori che se ne
occupano
hanno capito che si verifica soprattutto
quando abbiamo a che fare con set di
regole che sono articolati e dobbiamo
metterle alla prova con dei contesti
complessi
e questa però è la ricerca vede un po
alla nostra esperienza cosa è successo
quando abbiamo incominciato a imparare
quando siamo andati a scuola abbiamo
incontrato qualcuno
maestro un insegnante quello che ci
assegnava i compiti ci interrogava ci
spiegava la lezione ma prima di tutto
questo questa persona si è rivolta a noi
ha cominciato a chiamarci per nome ha
cominciato a occuparci a cuba apparsi di
noi e questo se voi ci pensate bene vuol
dire un po instaurare una relazione
esattamente come succede tra medico e
paziente la relazione terapeutica è la
base la premessa di tutto quello che
accade in seguito della diagnosi
dell'anamnesi prima ancora della
diagnosi e poi anche della cura qui
quando parliamo di cura parliamo di
terapia cos'è la terapia è un insieme di
procedimenti di interventi che sono
necessari per riguadagnare un equilibrio
che si è rotto nel nostro organismo
generando conseguenze indesiderate e
quindi farmacologicamente oppure con
degli interventi chirurgici o ricorrendo
magari al supporto di dispositivi
esterni cerchiamo di ricostruire questo
equilibrio meglio ancora di costruirne
uno nuovo
accettabile per il nostro organismo tra
l'altro non sempre ci si riesce
ecco perché quando parliamo di salute
prevenire è nettamente meglio che curare
anzi la prevenzione viene prima della
cura mira proprio a fare in modo che la
cura non sia necessaria
e quando parliamo di formazione
facciamo un parallelismo azzardato anche
quando parliamo di formazione esistono
dei malati
esistono dei soggetti che necessitano di
cura perché sono portatori di uno
squilibrio uno squilibrio tra le
competenze che effettivamente possiedono
e quelle che sono invece attese attese
dagli standard di verifica dei requisiti
d'esame dal mercato del lavoro ecco
soprattutto quando si parla di sfera
professionale sempre più ultimamente si
lamenta uno skill mismatch che cosa
significa un uno squilibrio un divario
tra le competenze attese e in questo
caso si parla soprattutto di competenze
digitali
attese da un mercato del lavoro
completamente trasformato ormai
dall'innovazione tecnologica e le
competenze che invece effettivamente i
lavoratori oggi in servizio possiedono
e allora che facciamo allora corriamo ai
ripari con corsi di formazione in gergo
si parla di corsi di race killing quando
puntiamo la riqualificazione dei
lavoratori per avviarli a un mestiere
nuovo magari perché la professione che
svolgevano è stata resa obsoleta dalla
trasformazione digitale oppure si parla
di corsi di upscaling che significa che
si forniscono strumenti o metodi nuovi
per svolgere la stessa professione
quello che abbiamo capito informazione e
che su questa situazione bisogna
per venire un po prima che si verifichi
bisognerebbe intervenire sin dagli anni
dell'istruzione obbligatoria
in effetti ci sono paesi nei quali sin
da questa epoca gli studenti vengono
avviati su percorsi molto precisi
abbastanza rigidi quasi per fare in modo
che le competenze che effettivamente
possederanno alla fine del percorso
siano le competenze davvero richieste
dalle professioni che si preparano a
svolgere
agire prima no quindi fare prevenzione
allora torniamo alla nostra domanda
quindi anche informazione prevenire è
meglio che curare
dipende se per cura noi intendiamo
questa terapia della inadeguatezza tra
l'altro tardi va certamente meglio
prevenire
però vedete esiste un altro significato
di cura un grande filosofo filosofo del
novecento ha definito la cura
l'atteggiamento fondamentale
dell'esserci cioè nell'essere umano nel
suo abitare il mondo
ecco questa cura non la definiamo
filosoficamente questo è il mio campo ma
proviamo a tornare all'esperienza
proviamo tornare a quei due lì di prima
il maestro e l'allievo ministro
l'allievo cosa fanno si guardano negli
occhi sono l'uno di fronte all'altro
hanno negli occhi l'uno la presenza
dell'altro la sua intera realtà con
tutte le sue perfezioni e imperfezioni
che in questo caso però non sono
sinonimo di inadeguatezza ma di identità
ecco chi fa formazione
prima di tutto ha in mente le persone
come sono prima ancora di come
potrebbero o come dovrebbero essere
ecco io credo che sia importante di
farli ripartire da qui noi abbiamo prima
parlato di prepararsi no
ed è giusto prepararsi nella formazione
è giusto pensare alla preparazione
prepararsi significa guardare al futuro
quindi alle potenzialità no alle
aspirazioni alle aspettative
vuol dire anche guardare le mancanze
alle lacune ai divari però gli stessi
occhi che guardano al futuro devono
essere saldamente radicati nel presente
non è solo questione di tempo ma anche
di spazio perché le persone sono qui e
ora per accompagnarla imparare bisogna
essere lì con loro e per loro
se questo non succede quando questo non
succede si verifica un po quello che
avrete sperimentato chi di voi ha figli
diciamo tra i 5 e 10 anni
prima dei 5 anni magari li prendiamo in
braccio risolviamo dopo dieci anni non
li prendiamo più quindi inutile pensarci
ma tra i 5 e 10 anni
magari ci è capitato una volta di dover
andare da qualche parte di avere un
appuntamento di dover prendere un
autobus non so andare dal medico
e però c'era nostro figlio intento a
giocare o intento a guardare un cartone
animato o magari a ammirare una vetrina
ecco allora in quel caso cosa facciamo
dobbiamo andare allora prendiamo per
l'amore al bambino lo strappo niamo e
cominciamo a camminare
allora pensate al nostro atteggiamento
in quel momento noi siamo tutti rivolti
in avanti al nostro obiettivo non ci
guardiamo indietro non ci voltiamo a
guardare cosa contiene la nostra mano
quello che la nostra mano strattona ecco
questo più che un accompagnamento è un
trascinamento
ed è questo quello che mi viene in mente
quando penso a un certo modo di fare
formazione che è un modo molto orientato
l'obiettivo molto consapevole del
rischio da evitare del problema da
risolvere e che quindi tende a mettere
al sicuro competenze e conoscenze prima
ho invece di mettere al centro le
persone che sono le portatrici di queste
competenze e di queste conoscenze questo
io lo definirei un modo preventivo di
fare formazione
invece vorrei provare a ripartire dalla
cura a mettere prima la cura
diciamo che la cura e questo
atteggiamento fondamentale questo modo
di consentire per noi il fatto di
rivolgerci agli altri di occuparci di
loro la cura una coltivazione dell'umano
e poi è importante avere uno scopo
modello un obiettivo assolutamente
ma quando impariamo lo scopo più
importante lì davanti ai nostri occhi
perché imparando stiamo diventando noi
stessi se invece mettiamo al primo posto
i rischi problemi di vari le lacune noi
non potremmo mai fare nient'altro che
riparare invece di costruire
ecco perché io credo che per fare
informazione si debba avere cura avere
cura significa accompagnare le persone
accompagnarle in quello che vogliono
realizzare
condividere la fiducia nelle loro
possibilità nelle loro capacità di
realizzare i loro progetti di superare i
loro problemi e le loro paure ma di
farlo a modo loro
rispettando il loro modo di essere
ecco io credo che senza
ripartire da questa umanità presente
senza coltivare la nostra umanità
presente non potremo mai costruire
l'umanità futura perché una persona che
impara non sta anzitutto gestendo un
rischio o risolvendo un problema una
persona che impara prima di ogni altra
cosa sta crescendo ed è a questo che va
accompagnato con cura grazie
[Applauso]